في خطوه متوقعه اعلنت تحالف العمل والحريه
المعارض في تركيا عدم طرح اي مرشح رئاسي
في الانتخابات القادمه ما يعني دعما لمرشح
المعارضه الرئيسي كمال
اين عمليه تقييم شامله لاعلان مرشح من
طرفنا في تحالف الحريه والعمل حيث كنا قد
اعلنا سابقا اننا سنسمي مرشحا لرئاسه بعد
تقييم الشامل نعلن رسميا باننا لن نقدم
مرشحا باسم التحالف لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه وسنتحمل مسؤوليتنا
التاريخيه في مواجهه نظام حكم الرجل
الواحد القائم حاليا
التحالف الذي يقوده حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
المؤيد للاكراد اتخذ هذا القرار بعد
اجتماع قياده الحزب الكردي مع كلجدار
اوغلو الاثنين الماضي حيث يسعى زعيم
المعارضه لكسب دعم الناخبين الاكراد
كممثلا عن تحالف الامه المعارض او ما بات
يعرف باسم الطاوله السداسيه هذا التحالف
تقدم بدوره رسميا الى المجلس الاعلى
للانتخابات بطلب ترشيحك
اتفاقنا
جئنا الى المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات مع
الاعضاء المعقرين في تحالف الامه قدمنا
طلبه ترشيح الرئيس الثالث عشر للجمهوريه
التركيه كماركل شيدار اوغلو
في المعسكر المقابل تبدو مهمه الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان صعبه في الانتخابات القادمه
في ظل دعم جديد تلقاه كلجدار اوكلو وايضا
ما ذكره نائب رئيس الوزراء السابق محمد
شمشك عن رفضه الانخراط في اي منصب حكومي
مع حكومه اردوغان القادمه في حال فاز
الرئيس بالانتخابات
[تصفيق]
قال انه لن يستمر في العمل السياسي ليس له
تاثير محتمل في الانتخابات برايه من جانب
المعارضه خصوصا يوجد استقطاب كبير وهم
يرون انه الوقت الانسب لرحيل اردوغان في
ضوء المستجدات الراهنه يحاول تحالف الشعب
الذي يقوده اردوغان تعزيز تحالفه وكسب
فئات جديده لذلك تحالف مع حزب الدعوه
الحره المدعوم من الاكراد المحافظين
لا شك ان هذه الانتخابات تمثل مساله حياه
او موت للقطبين الرئيسيين فيها وهما
اردوغان وكليجدار اوغلو لذلك من المنتظر
ان نشهد في الايام القادمه مزيدا من
التحركات تجاه التيارات سياسيه كانت على
الهامش يوما ما بغيت جذب اصواتها لاحد
المرشحين زيدان زنكلو العربيه اسطنبول